there is a saying in europe about the
british americans french and germans
if each is set a task and given six
hours to do it in
the american will finish his work in
four hours and fill the remaining time
by taking a leisurely stroll
the frenchman will finish in four hours
and spend the spare time drinking
singing and dancing the englishman will
finish the job in five hours and spend
the sixth hour working
at another task and the german will not
be able to finish the task in six hours
but will go on working through the night
it has to be said that this story sums
up well the characteristics of the four
nationalities
that europe and the eastern parts of
asia have been separate regions since
ancient times with hardly any
communication between them
may be inferred from the customs
embodied in the cultures of their races
the people of europe make their
livelihoods through competition with one
another
at the same time seeking to satisfy
their desire
for profit the character of their
political culture may be reduced to four
elements
the pursuit of personal goals
perseverance
obstinacy and self-centeredness
the individual nations of the west are
fiercely competitive
and possess a strong spirit of
independence based on their inhabitants
love of country
this is so intense that the nations
never miss an opportunity to avenge a
slight to their honor
even after hundreds of years western
people seem to possess
a more passionate sense of patriotism
than people in the east
thus there is a constant stream of
british visitors to belgium
who come to pay their respects at the
site of the battle of waterloo
whereas the french avoid the area
completely
[Music]
during the morning we sailed along the
coast of the region
called all the way to liverpool
nothing lay ahead but the smooth and
boundless sea
the local people had divided the land
neatly into fields
and cultivated it thoroughly and
meticulously
to the eye this landscape was a great
improvement on the rough and ready
american railroads
the area of the united kingdom as a
whole is 121
362 square miles and according to
statistics for 1871
its total population was 31 817 thousand
one hundred and eight its form location
size and population are very similar to
those of japan
for this reason the people of britain
are in the habit of referring to japan
as the briton of the east from the point
of view of economic power however
the disparity is immense lands belonging
to this country are spread across the
five
continents in asia its possessions
include most of
india and in the south seas the
australian continent and
new zealand the british boast that the
sun
never sets on their empire the spanish
said the same thing about their own
empire
when it was at its height among these
the greatest prophets are derived from
india an american has criticized this
state of affairs
saying that the british live like ants
in their little islands
owning fields in india where they
squeeze the fat from the people
while growing fatter themselves they
extract
profits from their colonies just as one
extracts juice
from a lemon they squeeze with all their
strength
until not a drop is left
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan have been great supporters of
content from me and my brother for a
while now
and all across youtube i've been using
their documentaries to brush up my
knowledge on a range of subjects
and have even been able to set up new
channels after being inspired by some of
their documentaries
and a good choice to go with this video
is kings of europe
france the habsburgs and the russian
sars just as the iwakura embassy
traveled through this
wild time in european history this
documentary gives
you the opportunity to do the same as
always magellan tv offers a great
parallel to our videos
and it's just one of more than 3 000
documentaries available
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership
today thanks
[Music]
the people who live in britain are
unable to be idle even for a moment
we heard it said that the spaniard makes
an occupation of sleeping all day but
the englishman's foot
never rests on the ground for more than
a moment in spain
therefore simply taking a shorter siesta
is enough to gain one a reputation for
hard work
but in london just walking at an
ordinary pace
gives the impression that one is an
idler as a result
many people simply run out of energy and
the numbers of the poor
are probably greater than in almost any
other country
the fact is that the vast profits which
are reaped year by year
are all garnered by the rich there is a
comprehensive system of laws to protect
them
so that those who lose their fortunes
are few and there are not many who start
up businesses all at once or suddenly go
bankrupt
the weather in britain is very
inconstant
rain does not come in prolonged
downpours or sudden cloud bursts
when the temperature falls a little the
sky becomes overcast for days on end
and a constant drizzle sets in
in the afternoon we went aboard the
victory which is moored permanently at
the dockside and manned by sailors of
the royal navy
furthermore because it is the ship on
which the great british admiral nelson
died at the historic battle of trafalgar
off the coast of spain
relics of him and many of his papers are
preserved on board
his glorious spirit will undoubtedly
live
for a thousand years by gracious
permission of the royal household we
were shown round buckingham palace
room after room is adorned with
priceless objects and curios
and there is an endless collection of
superb pictures whose beauty dazzles the
eye
we were not permitted to go into the
queen's dressing room and bedroom
she had departed for her holiday in
scotland leaving them in the state of
disorder in which they had been while
she was in residence
so her staff did not want strangers to
see them the present queen
is immensely popular among the british
people revered as a great monarch of a
kind
rarely seen since ancient times
in the afternoon accompanied by sir
harry parks and general alexander
we visited the following places first
the tower of london the ancient castle
of london
the upper part of the tower was the
jewel house where the monarch's jeweled
crowns and ceremonial regalia were kept
in an apartment comprising several rooms
there was a set of japanese armor said
to have been sent from japan as a gift
to
king charles ii there was also a
collection of japanese swords
but they were inferior pieces of the
kind found in any antique shop
are not worth looking at
at 11 in the morning we went to the
british museum
this is britain's national museum a vast
building
renowned throughout europe for its size
when one looks at the objects displayed
in its museums
the sequence of stages of a country's
civilization is immediately apparent to
the eye
and can be apprehended directly by the
mind
no country has ever sprung into
existence fully formed
the pattern in the nation's fabric is
always woven in a certain order
the knowledge acquired by those who
proceed is passed on to those who
succeed
the understanding achieved by earlier
generations is handed down
to later generations and so we move
forward
by degrees this is what is called
progress progress does not mean
discarding what is old and contriving
something which is entirely
new in the forming of a nation therefore
customs and practices arise
whose value is tested by constant use
so that when new knowledge appears it
naturally does so from existing sources
nothing is better than a museum for
showing the stages by which these
processes happen
seeing but once is better than hearing a
hundred times
calais is the most northerly port in
france and an important terminal for
people traveling to and from britain
we were served lunch in the hotel here
although britain and france are
separated by the narrowest of straits
it is quite extraordinary how very
different their languages sound
whereas the british talk in subdued
tones when the french speak their voices
take on
an impassioned note the two languages
have separate origins and are completely
different
the food too suddenly changes in flavor
although the peoples have had a constant
contact and have invaded each other's
countries for thousands of years
they remain divided by this narrow
stretch of water and maintain their own
cultural traditions
this shows that in defining a country's
boundaries
the inhabitants ancient customs are as
inalterable
as the natural frontiers of mountains
and rivers
as our lodgings were right in front of
the grand intersection where the arc de
triomphe stands
a site known in paris for its imposing
majesty
cloud and fog were swept even further
from our minds
and our spirits lifted
[Music]
we visited a factory which makes
chocolate
another noted product of france
chocolate is made from the beans of
cacao trees
which grow in the tropics and are
cultivated in abundance in such colonies
as
martinique and guadalupe the confections
here are the best to be found and are
wrapped in tin foil and decorated with a
lithograph picture
pasted on top these sweets provide
nourishment to the blood
and soothe the nerves with the advance
of european civilization
standards of food clothing and housing
have all risen
and spending is increasing continuously
it is the europeans who manufacture and
consume the products
but the raw materials are all imported
from the fertile lands of asia
africa america and australia when some
natural commodity is discovered and
become sought after
it can only be procured in a few places
at first
and thus commands an exceptionally high
price
the foremost objective of trade should
not be to provide
limited quantities of expensive goods
but to supply
large amounts at low prices the reason
the british and the french promote
production of commodities in their
colonies
is that it is extremely cheap there
[Music]
it is almost impossible to convey how
much customs vary from village to
village in the west
during our travels we mostly passed
through cities and rarely stayed in
villages
so he had very few opportunities to
observe local customs
nevertheless there are several which
could be mentioned here
the uniform of scottish soldiers is
completely different
from what is customary in england they
wear a strange
and ancient type of garment which hangs
down their legs
thus leaving six or seven inches around
their knees completely bare
now since scotland is not far from the
arctic circle
it must be harmful to the health to
expose one's knees like this
yet even in these enlightened times they
stubbornly cling to this practice
simply because it is their custom again
when ordinary european women are in
their finery
their bodies are naked above the breasts
but this is simply their custom
similarly
ear piercing and constriction of the
waist are simply customs
but also is the practice of wearing
shoes which squeeze the foot
simply because small feet are considered
more attractive
none of these practices are healthy
holland also goes by the name of the
netherlands
and to us in japan the country is known
as oranda
today it is one of the smaller nations
in europe 300 years ago the dutch sailed
overseas
establishing colonies in various parts
of the world and holland's power was
unchecked
as our country had rejected diplomatic
ties
and holland was the only nation allowed
to send vessels to our shores
the dutch made vast profits through
their control of all japanese products
reaching europe at a dinner party we
attended in holland
there are a number of ladies of quality
present one of them
seeing that all the men in our party had
black hair black
pupils and a similar bone structure
asked the japanese minister in holland
in puzzlement
if all men in japan had the same bone
structure as we had
on being informed that throughout japan
people were like us
she expressed astonishment and wondered
if it was rather unusual for a country
with a population 10 times that of
holland
to consist entirely the same race
it is a vulgar notion born of a
narrow-minded outlook
to suppose that other people because of
some minor difference in bone structure
or customs
are not our equals and a notion to which
educated people
pay no heed
the first time that we in japan heard
the name of this country
was probably when a prussian warship
arrived in nagasaki
in 1860. all that the people in our
country knew about prussia
was that it had a reputation in europe
as a strong nation
this is the leading country in europe in
terms of alcohol consumption
for each prussian drinks on average four
hectare liters of beer a year
while people in saxony drink an average
of six hectares
it was all very different from the
customs we observed in britain and
france
even inside the theaters men and women
do not refrain from drinking beer
this evening we had an invitation to
dinner with the minister of foreign
affairs
prince bismarck during the dinner this
evening the prince referred to the time
when he was young
saying nations these days all appear to
conduct relations with amity
and courtesy but this is entirely
superficial
for behind this facade lurks mutual
contempt
and a struggle for supremacy as you
gentlemen know
when i was a young boy prussia was weak
and poor the state of this small nation
at that time fills me with such
intense indignation that i could not
dispel the image from my mind
first so-called international law which
was supposed to protect the rights of
all nations
afforded us no security at all when
there was a dispute
the great powers would invoke
international law and stand their ground
if they stood to benefit
but if they stood to lose they would
simply change direction
and resort to military force
consequently
in the face of maneuvering with flattery
and contempt by the great powers
we invariably failed to protect our
right of independence
no matter how hard we tried incensed by
this
deplorable state of affairs we gathered
our strength as a nation and strove to
cultivate our patriotic spirit
in the decades since then up to the
present all we have ever set out to
achieve
is simply to uphold the autonomous right
of every
nation nevertheless we hear constant
expressions of horror from other
countries at the way prussia has used
force and they censor us for rejoicing
in our military prowess
and for depriving people of their
sovereign rights we hear of the distress
caused to nations by the way britain and
france abuse their power
coveting overseas colonies and
exploiting their resources
neither must you gentlemen relax your
vigilance
for having been born in a small nation
myself and knowing its state of affairs
intimately
this is a point i understand most deeply
so while japan
may now have amicable diplomatic
relations with a number of countries
its friendship with germany should be
the closest of all
because of the true respect in which we
hold the right of self-government
for the envoys listening during the
banquet these were significant words
indeed
and we appreciated the chance to learn
from the prince's eloquence
knowing full well what a master
tactician he is
in the world of politics
it was in russia that we ventured into
the remotest regions in the course of
our peregrinations around america
and europe as we traveled steadily
eastwards after leaving paris
signs of civilization became ever more
sparse
for all the talk about civilization and
development when the whole world is
taken into consideration
these notions amount to no more than the
light of a star
on the ground in one corner of the world
fully 90 of all dry land is still
desolate
here only the nobility are at all
advanced
and the common people are like slaves
[Music]
the eastern races are less inclined to
greed they submit themselves to moral
governance
their sovereigns are conscientious and
frugal and thus have raised their people
to great heights
the western races by contrast are given
to rampant greed
and are slow to correct their conduct as
for their rulers
it would not be a lie to say that they
tax the people on their lands heavily
and make themselves wealthy by keeping
the revenue for themselves
this explains why the notion of freedom
has sprung forth among the peoples of
europe
and why europe is seething with the
views of those who would wipe out the
rights of sovereigns
and establish the rights of the people
the peoples of the east and the west
are different in character they're
almost opposites
i suppose that the most powerful
countries in europe are the five
monarchies of britain
france germany austria and russia the
most influential are britain and france
while the most backward of them is
russia people in the west could not help
but seeing russia as a country
which has risen one notch above turkey
and yet the efforts the russians are
making to advance are inspired simply by
the desire to bestow upon their country
a lustre similar to that of the leading
countries
this is the nature of russia's reaction
to europe hitherto the japanese have
feared russia more than britain or
france
in the popular mind britain and france
seem to be trading countries like
holland
while germany and austria seem to be
countries struggling for power in europe
meanwhile russia the largest and most
powerful country
seems to be perpetually stalking the
land in a rapacious mood
and nursing ambitions of conquering the
world yet if so-called amity between
nations
whereby nations understand one another
and the strong and weak protect one
another
is considered to be superficial just a
mask
then surely it is not russia alone which
we ought to be suspicious of
the expansion of their territorial
possessions by britain and france offers
us
a true example of countries which
control the continents of the world
germany is not yet powerful overseas but
how can one say that this means it does
not have ambitions
if one suspects foreign countries of
being wolves
what country is beyond suspicion of
being a wolf
when it comes to determining strategic
policy we should have a clear grasp of
the true situation in the world
and ponder accurately whether we should
be most friendly to britain and france
to russia or to the states of germany
and austria
rome contains many remains dating back
two thousand years
and gazing at them one cannot but feel
wonder
at that time london and paris were areas
where barbarians lived
where brambles and weeds grew unchecked
in marshy areas and wild beasts wandered
at will
a place such as germany for example was
mostly made up of forests or plains
where the winters were harsh
some people painted their bodies or
tattooed themselves
others wore animal skins and they roamed
freely
ignorant as they were when they took
local produce in tribute to rome and saw
the splendor of roman civilization
and the magnificence of the city they
voluntarily reformed themselves
and joyously exchanged their habit of
idleness for better ways
what finally brought germany to its
present prosperous state
was precisely the elements which the
people had derived from the culture
of ancient rome our party had recently
visited the capitals of britain and
france
and now coming to rome we found dust
and rubbish blowing around and
considerable numbers of street urchins
thus have the wild thorny bushes of
ancient times become the civilization of
today
and the prosperity of yesteryear become
the degeneration of today
it seems to me that the vigor of
european civilization has natural limits
as if one part must be in decline while
another part is thriving
if britain france and germany are
flourishing now it is because their
progress has depended on elements
which originated in rome this became
abundantly clear when i saw the city for
myself
it is said that people who talk about
european civilization have all had to
come here once
to ponder its history for themselves how
true it is that the achievements of any
civilization are not simply a matter of
a day
and a night rather they are conceived
thousands of years earlier
and only much later emerge in all their
brilliance
[Music]
east and west lies so far apart that
they were beyond each other's reach
even had they wished to meet and
generally they are at variance due to
their vastly different
origins as we traveled around western
europe we did indeed feel that all men
are brothers
no matter where they come from yet if
one casts one's mind back
400 years nobody then could have
imagined for a moment
that the lands of europe would become
full and that there might be other lands
lying to the east of india
venice is a maritime city in the
northeastern part of italy
and consists of a group of islands
jutting out of the water at the end of
the adriatic sea
it is called the city of islands
on this day we immediately boarded a
gondola after emerging from the station
it felt as if we had placed ourselves in
a picture
of a river the houses and shops jostling
together were reflected in the water
the air was clean the sunlight pleasant
and the water suffused with an azure
tint
was marked by gentle ripples the boat
glided through the dim and misty air and
it felt as if one was being wafted
into the sky it is said the travelers
who come here
and share in these pleasures are usually
too enraptured
to think of going home
each european country has its strengths
and weaknesses
in commerce but the people there all
wish for commerce to thrive just as
people in the east
wish for an abundant harvest the
invitations which our embassy received
were prompted by nothing other than this
a desire to promote friendly relations
and thereby increase
trade with japan when we had audiences
with emperors
kings and queens all were received by
foreign ministers
the theme of their addresses was
invariably
trade they entertained us at lavish
banquets
where the conversation always turned to
trade
when we visited town halls chambers of
commerce and commercial exchanges
the speakers would unfailingly express a
hope for friendly relations
and increased trade with japan
when they did so all present would wave
their hats in the air
stamp their feet and cheer a high regard
for commerce permeates the innermost
hearts
of all europeans
you